في العام الماضي فقط ، كان مقطع فيديو لحملة مثل
هذا من بنيامين نتنياهو
لا يمكن تصوره
حرفيًا كأب لطريقة باللغة العربية
في احتضان رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي ،
يتناقض
مع هذا الفيديو من عام 2015 الذي يثير الخوف
من
الأقلية العربية العشرين في إسرائيل لإخافة قاعدة حزبه الليكود
للخروج والتصويت ،
فإن حكم اليمين في خطر.
ينتقل الناخبون العرب بأعداد كبيرة إلى
مراكز الاقتراع ،
ومن المتوقع أن تكون المنظمات اليسارية التي تنقلهم في حافلات في هذه الانتخابات قريبة جدًا
بحيث يمكن لمقعد أو مقعدين تحديد
من سيكون  رئيس الوزراء القادم
لهذا السبب ترى
مشهدًا مفاجئًا من بنيامين نتنياهو
وهو يخوض حملة انتخابية بين جمهور ناخب
اتُهم سابقًا
بالسخرية من حزب نتنياهو المتسرب.
نحن متفاجئون برؤية أنها تعمل
بشكل
فعال يؤمنون حقًا بالتعاون
معها  الليكود لذلك تابعنا هذه
الإستراتيجية وحتى الآن من الجيد أنه قد يتم
إجراء استطلاع رأي أجرته جامعة تل أبيب مؤخرًا
وجد أن ما يقرب من 25 في المائة من الناخبين الإسرائيليين العرب
يعتقدون أن نتنياهو هو أفضل
مرشح لرئاسة الوزراء
في قرية تايبيه.
قبل هذه الانتخابات واضح في
الشوارع
حيث يحاول المتظاهرون اليهود الإسرائيليون
إقناع السكان
المحليين بالتصويت ضد رئيس الوزراء ،
ويصرخ أحدهم في السيارات المارة بأن
نتنياهو
كاذب وأنهم بحاجة إلى طرده
ولكن قاطعها أحد السكان المحليين.  الرجل أسبارجا إسماعيل
الذي يقول أنه لا يوجد أحد مثل بيبي فقط
بيبي نتنياهو ، ليس هناك من هو أقوى
منه ،
وليس كل من في تايبيه من المعجبين به
، وعلى الرغم من أن خيبة الأمل تنتشر في
جميع أنحاء الأحزاب العربية ، كما
يقول إنه لأول مرة في
حياته  قد تترك ورقة اقتراعه فارغة ،
فلا داعي لأن تكون ذكيًا جدًا لترى
أننا نشعر بخيبة أمل
أولاً وقبل كل شيء جرائم العنف
قتل النساء والأطفال أيضًا.
البنية التحتية الشيء الثالث هو
كل الأشخاص العاطلين عن العمل الذين
تعرفون ما أنا في المنزل طوال الوقت
لأنني لا أشعر بالأمان
ألا يهتموا
بي.د أحمد طيبي من المخضرمين في السياسة الإسرائيلية
وعضو في البرلمان هنا لأكثر من
20 عامًا
يقول إنه من الحماقة
أن يعتقد الناخب العربي أن التصويت لنتنياهو
سيمنحهم القوة لمعالجة القضايا العربية
نتنياهو هو المشكلة ، فهو ليس
الحل
الأيديولوجي الصحيح مع الانتهازية
لكنه صالح في مثل هذه
الدولة الصغيرة ، قد يتوقف نجاح نتنياهو
على ما إذا كان  يمكنه إقناع ما يكفي
من هؤلاء الناخبين لنسيان الماضي